Esta es la última etapa este grupo de
cazadores alpinos está a punto de
completar la vuelta al Mont Blanc siete
días Y 170 kilómetros de marcha un reto
para Mark Timoteo tres soldados heridos
en
Madrid comenzamos inmediatamente con una
subida bastante pronunciada tenemos 910
metros de diferencia de altitud positiva
una vez en la cima pasamos por leflage y
luego un descenso de 1300 metros de
desnivel negativo hasta la Sur hoy
tenemos una proyección de unos 22 a 23
kilómetros
el 27avo bca o batallón de cazadores
alpinos fue movilizado para organizar
esta operación llamada tigerrate El
objetivo es que estos tres heridos
puedan encontrar sus montañas y
reconstruir sus vidas
su unidad fue desplegada en goji de
junio a octubre de 2021 cuatro meses de
operaciones anti yihadistas en el chajel
en contacto con el enemigo Durante los
cuales siete soldados resultaron
gravemente heridos
tuvo un accidente mientras se equipaba
para la guardia una granada defensiva
atada a su cinturón se soltó y explotó
en el accidente perdí las manos fui
alcanzado en la zona de la cadera donde
perdí mucha materia tenía una fractura
del cuello del fémur una ruptura del
tracto digestivo un hígado roto etcétera
es decir que he tenido muchas lesiones
Sí de hecho el plan original era volver
a alargar el hueso del pulgar para hacer
una pinza entre El pulgar y el meñique
pero luego el dedo no funcionó y ahora
está inmovilizado en esta posición tuve
que aprender a comer de nuevo porque ya
no era capaz de alimentarme tuve que
aprender a beber de nuevo tuve que
aprender a caminar de nuevo a vestirme y
alabarme como un bebé recién nacido
tiendo a compararme mucho con quién era
antes
y por eso todavía estoy en proceso de
duelo y de aceptación de quién soy ahora
en el momento del accidente Timoteo se
encontraba A tres metros de Emiliano y
cuando vio la granada con el pasador
extraído tuvo tiempo de darse la vuelta
para intentar protegerse llevaba su
chaleco antibalas pero recibió metralla
en todo el cuerpo un fragmento del
tamaño de una pelota de tenis alcanzó
una parte de su pantorrilla
que haga hasta hace unos meses no
estábamos seguros de que fuéramos a
recuperar la pantorrilla al 100% Así que
el recorrido del Mont Blanc me convence
de que mi pantorrilla está curada está
curada después de eso estaba acribillado
Así que todavía tengo astillas en las
articulaciones entonces tengo cuidado
con eso veremos que me depara el futuro
hasta aquí todo bien
en la explosión recibió 25 Trozos de
metralla en el cuerpo hoy en día quedan
11 que los cirujanos no pudieron extraer
[Aplausos]
está aquí mismo Sí allí allí
golpeó el hueso y pasó cerca de la
arteria Y eso es lo que más me ha dolido
lo más difícil fue saber que mi colega
estaba en una emergencia que ponía en
peligro su vida Esa fue la parte más
difícil una vez que la cicatrices se
desvanecen y las heridas se curan es
cuando aparece la lesión psicológica
me declararon en estado postraumático
leve
eran sobre todo pesadillas por la noche
me despertaba por la noche o no dormía
estuve un poco hiper vigilante al
principio pero por lo demás se me pasó
muy rápido especialmente después de que
mi colega fuera mejorando
estoy listo para ir de nuevo Es cierto
que la gente no entiende realmente
Cuando digo esto pero en este momento
todavía estoy en proceso de
reconstrucción voy a volver a trabajar
pronto pero si puedo si puedo volver
será con mucho gusto
timote pasó las pruebas psicológicas del
ejército y fue declarado apto para el
combate tras el tigerrate tiene previsto
participar en cursos para incorporarse a
la Infantería de montaña de élite
es argento Marc no volverá al frente su
nervio ciático está seccionado no siente
el pie izquierdo y camina con una férula
resultó herido en el atentado suicida
que marcó el inicio de la misión del 27a
o bca en malin ese día su pelotón estaba
escoltando un convoy en el centro de
gosi su grupo acababa de desembarcar de
un vehículo blindado cuando el
terrorista suicida atacó
el vehículo llegó lentamente no fue
ofensivo
fue desviado de su curso por las
combinaciones gestuales
un poco más tarde detrás de nosotros
sí un total de 8 heridos en este ataque
la reconstrucción para nosotros es una
misión
y hacerla juntos nos Recuerda la fuerza
que tenemos
la fuerza del grupo también permite a
los individuos enfrentarse a sus
demonios interiores
tras una semana de esfuerzo el grupo
cruza el arco que marca la meta
bien hecho cariño eres fuerte
es irreal ya que de todas formas ha
pasado un año es irreal en dos días ha
pasado un año desde que me dijeron que
Emily tuvo su accidente en Mali pero
estoy súper contenta y Súper orgullosa y
estoy detrás de él para impulsarlo
Quiero verle de nuevo con los esquís
montando en bicicleta y haciendo todo lo
que le gusta y luego continuar en el
ejército y eso es todo estoy orgullosa
de él
[Música]
emilian recibirá sus prótesis espera
volver a esquiar en enero antes de
intentar escalar el kilimanjaro en junio
de 2023